The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PROFESSOR: Last time, we began
a discussion of feedback.
And I briefly introduced a
number of applications.
For example, the use of feedback
in compensating for
non-ideal elements
in a system.
And also, as another example,
the use of feedback in
stabilizing unstable systems.
In this final lecture, what
I'd like to do is focus in
more detail on the use
of feedback to
stabilize unstable systems.
And the specific context in
which I'd like to do that is
in the context of the
inverted pendulum.
Now, I've referred to the
inverted pendulum in several
past lectures.
And, basically, as everyone
realizes, a pendulum is
essentially a rod with a
weight on the bottom.
And, naturally, an inverted
pendulum is just
that, upside down.
And so it's essentially a
rod that's top-heavy.
And the idea with the inverted
pendulum is, although by
itself it's unstable around a
pivot point at the bottom, the
idea is to apply an external
input, an acceleration,
essentially to keep
it balanced.
And we've all probably done
this type of thing at some
point in our lives, either
childhood or not.
And so that's the system that
I'd like to analyze and then
illustrate in this lecture.
Now, the context in which we'll
do that is not with my
son's horse, but actually with
an inverted pendulum which is
mounted on a cart.
And first I'd like to go through
an analysis of it, and
then we'll actually see
how the system works.
So basically, then, the system
that we're talking about is
going to be a system which
is a movable cart.
Mounted on the cart is a rod
with a weight on the top.
And this then becomes the
inverted pendulum.
And the cart has an external
acceleration applied to it,
which is the input that we
can apply to the system.
And then, in general, we can
expect some disturbances.
And I'm going to represent the
disturbances in terms of an
angular acceleration, which
shows up around the weight at
the top of the rod.
So if we look at the system,
then, as I've kind of
indicated it here, basically
we have two inputs.
We have an input, which are
the external disturbances,
which we can assume that we
have no control over.
And then there is the
acceleration that's apply to
the cart externally, or in the
case of balancing my son's
horse, it's the movement
of my hand.
And then, through the system
dynamics, that ends up
influencing the angle
of the rod.
And we'll think of the
angle of the rod
as the system output.
And basically the idea, then,
is to try to keep that angle
at 0 by applying the appropriate
acceleration.
Now, as I've mentioned several
times previously, if we know
exactly what the system dynamics
are, and if we know
exactly what the external
disturbances are, then
theoretically we can choose an
acceleration for the cart
which will exactly balance the
system, or balance the rod.
However, since the system is
inherently unstable, any
deviation from that model-- in
particular, any unanticipated
external disturbances--
will excite the instability.
And what that means is that
the rod will fall.
So the idea, then, is, as we'll
see, to stabilize the
system by placing feedback
around it.
In particular through a
measurement of the output
angle, processed through some
appropriate feedback dynamics,
using that to control the
acceleration of the cart.
And if we choose the feedback
dynamics correctly, then, in
fact, we can end up with a
stable system, even though the
open-loop system is unstable.
Well, as a first step, let's
analyze the system in its
open-loop form.
In particular, let's analyze the
system without feedback,
demonstrate that, indeed, it is
unstable, and then see how
we can stabilize it
using feedback.
So the system, then, is--
as we've indicated, the
variables involved are the
measured angle, which represents
the output, the
angular acceleration due to
external disturbances, and
then there is the
applied external
acceleration on the cart.
So these represent the
variables, with L representing
the length of the rod, and s of
t I indicate here, which we
won't really be paying attention
to, as the position
of the cart.
And without going into the
details specifically, what
we'll do is set up the equation,
or write the
equation, in terms of balancing
the acceleration.
And if you go through that
process, then the basic
equation that you end up with
is the equation that I
indicate here.
And this equation, then, tells
us how the basic forces, or
accelerations, are balanced,
where this is the second
derivative of the angle.
And then we have the
acceleration due to gravity,
reflected through the angular
acceleration times the sine of
the angle, the angular
acceleration due to the
external disturbances, and
finally, the angular
acceleration due to the
motion of the cart.
Now, this equation, as it's
written here, is a nonlinear
equation in the angle
theta of t.
And what we'd like to do is
linearize the equation.
And we'll linearize the
equation by making the
assumption that the angle is
very small, close to 0.
In other words, what we'll
assume is that we're able to
keep the rod relatively
vertical.
And our analysis, because
we're linearizing the
equations, will obviously
depend on that.
So making the assumption that
the angle is small, we then
assume that the sine of the
angle is approximately equal
to the angle, and the cosine of
the angle is approximately
equal to 1.
That will then linearize
this equation.
And the resulting equation,
then, in its linearized form,
is the one that I
indicate here.
So we have an equation of
motion, which linearizes the
balance of the accelerations.
And what we see on the
right-hand side of the
equation is the combined inputs
due to the angular
acceleration of the rod and the
acceleration of the cart.
And on the left-hand side of
the equation, we have the
other forces due to the
change in the angle.
So this is, then, the
differential equation
associated with the open-loop
system, the basic dynamics of
the system.
And if we apply the Laplace
transform to this equation and
solve for the system function,
then the basic equation that
we're left with expresses the
Laplace transform of the
angle, equal to the system
function, the open-loop system
function, times the Laplace
transform of
the combined inputs.
And I remind you again that our
assumption is that this is
an input that we have
no control over.
This is the input that
we can control.
And the two together,
of course, form
the combined input.
Now, we can, of course, solve
for the poles and 0's.
There are no 0's.
And there are two poles, since
this is a second-order
denominator.
And looking at the poles in the
s-plane then, we see that
we have a pair of poles, one at
minus the square root of g
over L, and one at plus the
square root of g over L.
And the important observation,
then, is that while this pole
represents a stable pole, the
right half-plane pole
represents an unstable pole.
And so this system, in fact,
is an unstable system.
It's unstable because what we
have is a pole in the right
half-plane for the
open-loop system.
Now, before we see how to
stabilize the system, let's,
in fact, look at the mechanical
setup, which we
won't turn on for now, and just
see essentially what this
instability means and what the
physical orientation of the
equipment is.
So what we have, which you just
saw a caricature of in
the view graph, is an
inverted pendulum.
This represents the pendulum.
And it's mounted with the pivot
point at the bottom.
It's mounted on a cart.
And here we have the cart.
And this is a pivot point.
And, as you can see, the
cart can move back
and forth on a track.
And the external acceleration,
which is applied to the cart,
is applied through this cable.
And that cable is controlled
by a motor.
And we have the motor at
this end of the track.
And so as the motor turns,
then the cart will
move back and forth.
OK.
Now, since the system
is not turned on
and there's no feedback--
in fact, the system, as we just
saw in the transparency,
is an unstable system.
And what that instability means
is that, for example, if
I set the angle to 0 and then
let it go, then as soon as
there's a slight external
disturbance, it
will start to fall.
Now, you can imagine that not
only is the system unstable as
it is, but certainly can't
accommodate changes in the
system dynamics.
For example, if we change,
let's say, the
weight of the pendulum.
So if we thought, for example,
of changing the weight by,
let's say, putting something
like a glass with something in
it on top, and I think about
trying to balance it by
itself, obviously that's hard.
In fact, I would say, without
turning the system on,
guaranteed to be impossible.
So the basic system, as we've
just analyzed it, is
inherently an unstable system.
The instability reflecting in
the fact that the pendulum,
following its own natural
forces, will tend to fall.
And now what we want to look at
is how, through the use of
feedback, we can, in fact,
stabilize the system.
So let's first, once again, look
at the open-loop system.
And the open-loop system
function that we saw was a
system function of this form, 1
over Ls squared minus g, and
that represents the system
function associated with the
two inputs, one being the
external disturbances, the
other being the externally
applied acceleration.
And the system function here
represents the system dynamics.
And the resulting output
is the angle.
Now, the feedback, the basic
strategy behind the feedback,
is to in some way use the
measured angle, make a
measurement of the angle, and
use that through appropriate
feedback dynamics to stabilize
the system.
And so with feedback applied
around the system then, there
would be some measurement of
the angle through some
appropriately chosen
feedback dynamics.
And that then would determine
for us the applied external
acceleration corresponding to
what the motor does by pulling
the cable back and forth.
And we would like to choose
G of s so that the overall
system is stable.
Now, as you recall from the
lecture last time, with the
feedback around the system and
expressed here in terms of
negative feedback, the overall
transfer function then is the
transfer function associated
with the basic feedback loop,
where H of s is the open-loop
system and G of s corresponds
to the feedback dynamics.
Now, that's the basic
strategy.
We haven't decided yet how to
choose the feedback dynamics.
And that becomes
the next step.
And we want to choose the
dynamics in such a way that
the system ends up
being stabilized.
Well, I think the thing to do is
just simply begin with what
would seem to be the most
obvious, which is a simple
measurement of the angle.
Let's take the angular
measurements, feed that back,
let's say through a
potentiometer and perhaps an
amplifier, so that there's some
gain, and see if we can
stabilize the system simply
through feedback which is
proportional to a measurement
of the angle, what.
Is typically referred to as
"proportional feedback." Well,
let's analyze the results
of doing that.
Once again we have the basic
feedback equation, where the
open-loop transfer function
is what we had developed
previously, given by the
second-order expression.
Now, using proportional
feedback, we choose the
acceleration a of t to be
directly proportional through
a gain constant or attenuation
constant K1, directly
proportional to the measured
angle theta of t.
And consequently the system
function in the feedback path
is just simply a gain
or attenuate K1.
So this, then, is the
system function for
the feedback path.
Well, substituting this into
the closed-loop expression,
then the overall expression for
the Laplace transform of
the output angle is, as I
indicate here, namely that
theta of s is proportional
through this system function.
So the Laplace transform of the
input X of t-- and let me
remind you that X of t, the
external disturbances, now
represent the only input,
since the other input
corresponding to the applied
acceleration to the cart is
now controlled only through
the feedback loop.
So we have this system function,
then, for the
closed-loop system.
We recognize this once again
as a second-order system.
And the poles of this
second-order system are then
given by plus and minus the
square root of g minus K1,
divided by L. So K1, the
feedback constant, clearly
influences the position
of the poles.
And let's look, in fact,
at where the
poles are in the s-plane.
Well, first of all, with K1
equal to 0, which, of course,
is no feedback and corresponds
to the open-loop system, we
have the poles where they
were previously.
And if we now choose K1, let's
say less than 0, then what
will happen as K1 becomes more
and more negative, so that
this term is more and more
positive, is that the left
half-plane pole will move
further into the left
half-plane, the right half-plane
pole will move
further into the right
half-plane.
So clearly with K1 negative,
this pole, which represents an
instability, becomes
even more unstable.
Well, instead of K1 negative,
let's try K1 positive and see
what happens.
And with K1 positive, what
happens in this case is that
the left half-plane pole moves
closer to the origin, the
right half-plane pole moves
closer to the origin.
What one would hope is that they
both end up in the left
half-plane at some point.
But, in fact, they don't.
What happens is that eventually
they both reach the
origin, split at that point,
and travel along the
j-omega-axis.
Now, this movement of the poles,
as we vary K1 either
positive or negative, what we
see is that with the open-loop
system, as we introduce
feedback, those basic poles
move in the s-plane, either this
way, as K1 becomes more
negative, or for this particular
case, if K1 is
positive, they move in together,
split, and move
along the j-omega-axis.
And that locus of the poles,
in fact, is referred to in
feedback terminology as the
"root locus." And as is
discussed in much more detail in
the text, there are lots of
ways of determining the root
locus for feedback systems
without explicitly solving
for the roots.
For this particular example, in
fact, we can determine the
root locus in the most
straightforward way simply by
solving for the roots
of the denominator
of the system function.
Now, notice that in this case,
these poles, with K1 positive,
have moved together.
They move along the
j-omega-axis.
And before they come
together, the
system is clearly unstable.
Even when they come together
and split, the system is
marginally stable, because,
in fact, the system
would tend to oscillate.
And what that oscillation
means is that with the
measurement of the angles,
essentially if the poles are
operating on the j-omega-axis,
what will happen is that
things will oscillate
back and forth.
Perhaps with the cart moving
back and forth trying to
compensate, and the rod
sort of moving in
the opposite direction.
In any case, what's happened
is, with just proportional
feedback, we apparently
are unable to
stabilize the system.
Well, you could think that the
reason, perhaps, is that we're
not responding fast enough.
For example, if the angle starts
to change, perhaps, in
fact, we should make the
feedback proportional to the
rate of change of angles,
rather than
to the angle itself.
And so we could examine the
possibility of using what's
referred to as "derivative
feedback."
In derivative feedback, what we
would do is to choose, for
the feedback equation, or for
the feedback system function,
something reflecting a
measurement of the derivative
of the angle.
And so here again, once again,
we have the open-loop system
function with derivative
feedback.
We'll attempt to--
or we will use this feedback.
And acceleration, which instead
of being proportional
to the angle, as it was in the
previous case, an acceleration
which is proportional to the
derivative of the angle.
And so the basic feedback
dynamics, or feedback system
function, is then G of s
is equal to K2 times s.
The multiplication by s
reflecting the fact that in
the time domain it's measuring
the derivative of the angle.
The associated system function
is then indicated here.
And if we solve again this
second-order equation for its
roots, that tells us that the
location of the poles are
given by this equation.
And so now what we would want to
look at is how these poles
move as we vary the derivative
feedback constant K2.
So let's look at the root
locus for that case.
And first, once again, we have
the basic open-loop poles.
And the open-loop poles consist
of a pole on the left
half-plane and a pole on
the right half-plane,
corresponding in this equation
to K2 equal to 0.
That is, no feedback
in the system.
If K2 is negative, then what you
can see is that this real
part will become
more negative.
Since K2 is squared here, this
is still a positive quantity.
And, in fact, then with K2 less
than 0, the root locus
that we get is indicated
by this.
Now, notice, then, that this
right half-plane pole is
becoming more unstable.
And the left half-plane
pole likewise is
becoming more unstable.
And this point, by the way,
corresponds to where this pole
ends up, or where the root
locus ends up, when K2
eventually becomes infinite.
So clearly K2 negative is not
going to stabilize the system.
Let's try K2 positive.
And the root locus dictated by
this equation, then, is what I
indicate here.
The left half-plane pole moves
further into the left
half-plane.
That's good.
That's getting more stable.
The right half-plane pole is
moving closer to the left
half-plane, but unfortunately
never gets there.
And, in fact, it's when K2
eventually becomes infinite
that this pole just gets to
the point where the system
becomes marginally stable.
So what we found is that with
proportional feedback, we
can't stabilize the system, with
the derivative feedback,
we can't stabilize the system,
by themselves.
And a logical next choice is to
see if we can stabilize the
system by both measuring the
angle and at the same time
being careful to be responsive
to how fast that angle is
changing, so that if it's
changing too fast, we can move
the cart or our hand
under the inverted
pendulum more quickly.
Well, now then what we want
to examine is the use of
proportional plus derivative
feedback.
And in that case, we then have a
choice for the acceleration,
which is proportional with one
constant to the angle and
proportional with another
constant to the
derivative of the angle.
And so the basic system
function, then, with
proportional plus derivative
feedback, is a system function
which is K1 plus K2 times s.
We then have an overall
closed-loop system function,
theta of s, which is given
by this equation.
And so the roots of this
equation then represent the
poles of the closed-loop
system.
And those poles involve
two parameters.
They involve the parameter K2,
which is proportional to the
derivative of the angle, and
the constant K1, which is
proportional to the angle.
And we'll, first of all, examine
this just with K2
positive, because what we can
see is that as we vary K1, if
K2 were negative, that would,
more or less immediately, put
poles into the right
half-plane.
And the more negative K2
got, the larger this
term is going to get.
So, in fact, as it will turn
out, we can stabilize the
system, provided that
we choose K2 to be
greater than 0.
All right.
Now, with K2 greater than 0,
what happens in the location
of the poles is that if K2 is
greater than 0, and we choose
K1 greater than 0--
I'm sorry.
We choose K1 equal to 0, then in
effect the influence of K2
is to shift the poles of the
open-loop system slightly.
And so with K2 greater than 0
and K1 equal to 0, we have a
set of poles, which are
indicated here, and so this is
just a shift, slight shift, to
the left, depending on the
value of K2, a shift to the left
of the open-loop poles.
Now, as we vary K1, and in
particular we're going to
choose K1 greater than 0, what
happens is that the poles will
begin to move together, as they
did previously when we
looked at the variation of K1.
The poles will move together,
reach a point where we have a
second-order pole, and then
those poles will split and
move parallel to the
j-omega-axis.
So what's indicated here
is the root locus.
And what this represents, then,
as long as we make K1
large enough so that this poles
moves into the left
half-plane, is that
it represents
now a stable system.
OK.
So what we've seen is that
proportional feedback by
itself or derivative feedback by
itself won't stabilize the
system, whereas with the right
choice of feedback constants,
proportional plus derivative
feedback will.
And we saw that basically by
examining the root locus in
the s-plane.
All right.
Well, let's actually watch
the system in action.
And I described it to
you previously.
Basically, an inverted
pendulum on a cart.
And so I still have it off.
And, of course, we have
the pendulum.
And as I indicated, it's
pivoted at the base.
And the angle is measured by a
potentiometer that we have
attached to the pivot point.
And the measurement of the angle
is fed back through this
wire to a motor that we have at
the other end of the table.
And then that motor basically
is used to provide the
acceleration to drive
the cart.
OK.
Well, let's turn it on.
And when we turn it on,
it'll take just
an instant to stabilize.
And fortunately we have the
constants set right, and there
we have now the stabilization
of an unstable system.
Remember that with the feedback
off, the system is
unstable because the pendulum
will fall, whereas now it's
stabilized.
Now, also, as you can see, not
only have we stabilized it,
but we're able to compensate
through the feedback to
changes in the external
disturbances.
For example, by tapping it,
because of the feedback and
the measurement of the angle,
it will more or less
automatically stabilize.
Now, in addition to being stable
in the presence of
external disturbances, it also
remains stable and remains
balanced even if we were to
change the system dynamics.
And let me just illustrate that
with the glass that we've
talked about before.
Let's first not be too bold, and
we'll take the liquid out
of the glass.
And presumably if it can adjust
to changes in the
system dynamics, then if I put
the glass on, in fact, it will
remain balanced.
And indeed it does.
And let me point out, by the
way, that I don't have to be
very careful about exactly where
I position the glass.
And furthermore, I can change
the overall system even
further by, let's say for
example, pouring a liquid in.
And now let me also comment that
I've changed the physics
of it a little bit.
Because the liquid can slosh
around a little bit, it
becomes a little more
complicated a system.
But as you can see, it still
remains balanced.
Now, if we really don't want to
be too conservative at all,
we could wonder whether, with
the feedback constants we
have, we could, in
fact, balance the
pitcher on the top.
And, well, I guess we may
as well give that a try.
And so now we're changing the
mass at the top of the
pendulum by a considerable
amount.
And, again, the system basically
can respond to it.
Now, this is a fairly
complicated system.
The liquid is sloshing around.
We, in fact, as you can see,
have an instability right now,
although it's controlled.
And that's because the physics
of the dynamics has changed.
And we can put a little bit more
mass into the system, and
maybe or maybe not that will cut
down on the instability.
OK.
Well, in fact, what happened
there is that we increased the
mass at the top of the
pendulum slightly.
And that provided just
enough damping to
stabilize the system.
OK.
Well, with this lecture and
this demonstration, this
concludes this entire
set of lectures.
It concludes it especially if
the pitcher happens to fall.
But, seriously, this concludes
the set of lectures as we have
put them together.
And let me just comment that,
as a professor of mine once
said, and which I've never
forgotten, the purpose of a
set of lectures, or of a course,
or, for that matter
anything that you study, is not
really to cover a subject,
but to uncover the subject.
And I hope that, at least to
some degree, we were able to
uncover the topic of signals
and systems through this
series of lectures.
There are a lot of topics that
we got only a very brief
glimpse into.
And I hope that at least what
we've been able to do is get
you interested enough in them so
that you'll pursue some of
these on your own.
And so I'd like to conclude by
thanking you, both for your
patience and your interest.
And I hope that you have enough
interest to pursue some
of these topics further.
Thank you.
FILMING DIRECTOR: Okay.
That's a wrap.